hey everybody it's Mike from order flows
and welcome to today's video today is
Wednesday January 25th 2023 and you know
we ended up the day you know slightly
lower for the day
um you know not much change but if
you're just looking at you know what the
the net change was for the day I think
it was kind of a quiet day but actually
you know it's quite the opposite we
opened up last night and proceeded to
sell off then when Europe came in sold
off some more when the U.S session cash
opened up we sold off some more made new
lows
um just right after the cash open and we
kept going lower then we put in this
tremendous Rally from you know the low
was uh 63 and uh a quarter all the way
up almost to we got up to you know the
opening price didn't take out the high
but you can see right now in the evening
session we just reopened a little while
ago we are starting to March back up
testing yesterdays or the previous
sessions hi so what I want to talk about
is you know what were some of the
interesting signs in the order flow from
the time the cash opened
um like I said you know we were under
this pressure mostly overnight this was
uh the five o'clock reopen over here and
into Asia we're just sort of trading
near our lows London opened up
that uh you know was that one two
o'clock here this is two right here and
then we started to sell off some more
into new lows lower lower lower and then
we rallied so let's take a look at the
order flow and again you know coming
into
the cash
session
um you know seven o'clock okay so we
started making here at 7 30 started
making new lows again
um you know taking out 95 and a half you
know getting down to 94 and just
marching down you don't really see any
bounce
um yet okay and you know 740 there was
you know he finally got a green bar
coming in here
um but then it just kept marching down
lower the every time we hit the low you
know never really rallied up at all now
you know if you remember some of those
videos I was posting last week talking
about divergences right now granted you
know this Market had been selling off
all night and
when we're coming into the U.S session
okay you start seeing you know some more
divergences you see sort of this triple
bottom here it hit it at 751 758 8
o'clock we got a couple divergences here
came in took it out
and then we bounced up around just after
eight o'clock we had a little bit of a
bounce from this new low at 85 and a
half up to you know 91.5 six point rally
then going sideways now at this point
right you're not gonna really want to
take any position ahead of the cash open
because you don't know
um
you know which way it's going to go
although granted you know it's been
under pressure all night so probably to
the downside and we get another
Divergence okay so 832 we have a
Divergence
and back here at 7 58 8 o'clock we had a
couple divergences so we took those out
and again you know I like to
I like to trade
failed divergences so you know I'm
looking to get short here now the only
issue that I have with this trade like
this is
happening right after the cash open now
I like to let the market settle right I
worked on a trading desk for you know
two decades and I know
up until the cash closed the cash open
is going to be the busiest time of the
day right it's going to be the time
where you know the execution desks have
all these
um orders that start on the cash open
you know view app
um you know the entire trading day or V
web for the first five minutes view app
for the first hour and I like to just
you know just based on my own experience
and I know how the cash opened
um can move and I just like to let it
settle that's just me
so I'm not really looking to take any
trade even though you know I honestly I
probably would have liked to sold it
here around you know to these new lows
if this was like say 9 30 as opposed to
8 30.
um it did did it make a new low yeah
technically it did I mean you can see if
you had a stop in here to get short just
below this low you know let's call it 83
you know it trades down to what 80 and a
quarter
fair enough technically yeah it did make
a new low yeah look at me I'm right but
you know I'm not gonna get much out of
that trade for me this this would have
been you know getting short here
wouldn't have been a good trade location
however
we get another Divergence this time we
have a Divergence and a ratio so we have
a new low with that positive Delta this
time we have a bullish ratio is telling
me there's price exhaustion at this low
here right that's this blue number 34.25
and for me that is a bullish signal so
you know even if I had gotten short here
at 83
getting this bullish signal after that
is you know assigned to get out of the
trade take the loss rather than let it
come up here stop you out wherever your
stop is going to be because while I have
three failed divergences
in this case going down I'd be looking
for a trend date down
granted it's already been trending down
anyway
um you know I'm a little worried about
my capacity for a short you know how
much further can it go obviously it did
go a bit further later in the morning I
say not later in the morning but you
know within another hour but you still
got a nice bounce here but this is one
of those trades right I've talked about
this and
a lot of my webinars that I do I talk
about this in my weekly Group Training
is when you have a Divergence in this
case a bullish Divergence because it's
at the low
and a bullish ratio whether it's a ratio
bonds high or ratio bonds low that's
this blue number right your normal ratio
your normal order flow is this right the
black number underneath the bar the 2.1
the 8.23 so this is telling me there's
price exhaustion this is a ratio bounds
low
so when I have you know a ratio that I
like in the order flow telling me that
is either price exhaustion or Price
defense in this case this is price
exhaustion it's coupled with a
Divergence
then that's just an automatic trade
right so it's a trade I'm looking to get
long in anyway and
in this next bar right what do we have
we got that value area that's been
abandoned okay so I've got a couple of
things going for me although this bar
right here is this sort of an automatic
one
um to get the next bar having that
abandoned value where it just gives it a
little bit more Credence and you know we
do manage to Rally from you know around
the 85 86 level all the way up into the
mid 90s here okay but we're running into
whoops this Zone up in here now this
green bar right this is a abandoned
value area from earlier this green bar
it actually looks very bullish all right
I'm going to talk about some of these
green bars like this one here this one
here
looking at this this is the type of bar
I'm looking for the market to start to
scream upwards right go go just you know
go up because I'm seeing the momentum
picking up I'm seeing you know a stacked
buying and balance in here I'm seeing
you know very little counter trade in
here it's almost The Sweep you know as
it's going up which is nice to see I'm
seeing heavy volume at the top of the
bar and it sort of go sideways and then
again another bar strong positive Delta
um this time you don't have stacked
imbalances they're a bit spread out you
got two and then one up here another two
here another one up here that's
something that I like to see and I want
to see follow through okay
but again you should already be long
from 86 but when I see something like
this bar then this bar I'm thinking we
hit 4 000
um but then it just stalls out up here
okay I see Supply coming in here in the
order flow you can see that the 269 the
246 which is you know not what you like
to see you mean earlier in the bar you
know there was some nice aggressive
buying you know it's a bar that's got a
positive Delta of 305 but the max Delta
was plus 905 so it was telling me it was
very strong at one point right almost a
thousand positive Delta
at one point in this bar then it just
gave it all back and well not all of it
back it settled at just 305.
and then it just starts drifting down
okay once it starts drifting down you
know that's one that's your sign to get
out
um but more importantly it's a sign that
maybe the selling is coming back into
the market right you know people say
well yeah it's an obvious it's a
shooting star Candlestick you gotta get
short on you know there's some other
things in here like this imbalance
you've seen some trap Traders up in
there and then we come back down and
again so now keep in mind right even
though this was bullish here this
Divergence and this ratio I've got a
Divergence here I've got a Divergence
here
and I got those two earlier right here
okay so that's one two three four right
here at this 80 level 80 and a quarter
so you just drop in a Cell stop at 80
even
to get short okay getting long hairs is
an opportunity then you should hopefully
you can recognize that it's not working
out in here obviously at least the value
area is starting to come off a bit right
red red
strong negative Delta here
but definitely you'd want to get short
again this time right you should have
maybe got short over here at 82. it took
a loss and you got long hair hopefully
you made it back in this trade then you
should still be looking to get short
here right around the 80 area
um
and when we came down and powered
through this low it actually triggered
some stops in here you can see this
stack selling and balance the 218 the
463 the 94 the 168 the 210.
all right so you know you got to stop in
here at 80 probably you filled somewhere
around you know 79 and a half 79 and a
quarter and then it just drops down over
the next few minutes
um one two three four bars four minutes
right down to around the 71-ish area
before it goes sideways then you got
another Divergence coming in here all
right this time you have no ratio
right it's just 3.79 so it's just
telling you it's a regular order flow
okay it's not an area to get long off of
bounces up a little bit runs into this
red candle where you got this abandoned
value area
and then it just
comes off tests that low doesn't hit
that low so you know while this was
looking
bearish in here
you know you should have already been
short from up here
um you know around the 80 area 79 and a
half down to you know for me you know 72
you're looking at this one bar here it's
it's kind of bearish right and you know
forget about that big sharp move up when
you're looking here all right if you're
already
short right you're not looking to take a
fresh short here if you took your
profits
would you want to get short here again
you could take the shot I mean I still
think there's probably some capacity for
this Market to go lower but again if
you're getting short here you still got
to have a stop in right and it's going
to be on the other side of this value
area then the next bar right it comes in
and it closes now it's a green up candle
okay so you know it started to move away
but this is where you got to be careful
right if you're trading an abandoned
value area you don't want the market
sort of coming back up towards it when
you're looking to get short
okay what you'd rather see is is a red
candle coming in here you'd rather see
the price action going down now people
can say well it didn't trade down right
it traded all the way down to 70. yes it
did but the bar is still closing up so
regardless you know if you still want to
pull the trigger and get short off of
this bar even though it's a green candle
okay you know you're getting short at
72. you still got to have a stop up here
you know 76 and a three-quarter 77. so
you know you're risking Five Points
there
and then you stopped out now Market
starts running up okay
starts running all the way back up to 86
and then
marches right back down and again you're
getting some you know looks like some
bullish candles coming in you got a gap
in the value here Gap in the value here
Gap in the value here so you got three
upward gaps in value
and
now I haven't done the studies on this
but I know that when I say I haven't
done studies is you know I haven't sat
down and gone through years of charts
looking at the value areas to determine
you know what percentage fails after
three but I do know when you get three
in a row sort of the the power of three
the market does have a tendency to pull
back okay and in this case it pulled
back through all those levels right
through this Gap through this Gap and
coming into this Gap here
oftentimes you do get two right but you
know three sometimes is a bit over
extended right Market just got ahead of
itself and sort of came back down and
you know filled this Gap filled this Gap
and tried to fill this Gap but again
nothing overly bearish in here on this
move down
um and we do come up and then we start
to move back down now here's a
bar the Delta is exactly zero and people
are like oh my gosh you know Delta zero
that doesn't mean anything it's just
more of a coincidence that it landed on
zero it could have been plus one it
could have been minus five
um
and then
again nothing screaming at you get long
get short
and then this bar comes in
okay you got one two three four five six
seven eight nine ten bars where the
value is overlapping in here then you
Gap up
all right gap between this one and this
one
you have this value area up here
okay this bar and it closes below the
value area that's not a good sign
closing below the value area right you
have the value area and it's abandoned
but it's abandoned to the downside it's
a bullish value area because it's a
green candle
however you got a couple bearish things
going on in there right sometimes it's
you want to take these things on the
surface and say oh there's there's an
abandoned value area here it's green so
it must be bullish but
take it a step further don't just take
it on the surface one we close below the
value area so we formed our value up
here but now we're rejecting that value
area
to the next bar
doesn't even trade back into it and it's
a red candle so on the surface it looks
bullish but
when you lift up the
you know the carpet to see what's
underneath it's actually very bearish
and you can see how this Market sold off
again you're not going to know how it's
really developing you have the first
sign in here by closing below this value
area and the second sign here as you
sell off
and then
once this bar is confirmed you know in
closing down you should be thinking
short definitely not long either short
or or no trade and you know from the
74-ish area right down to immediately
down to the 64. where we make a new low
and we have another Divergence okay so
over here you had another Divergence you
know if you wanted to trade it you know
you could have put a stop in here 69 and
a quarter 69 although it did pull back
immediately up to 75 and a half before
selling down
um but then it hits this new low here
now this was interesting okay because
this low
that's the low of the day right that's
this low here right before the market
shot up
okay so again you had some you know a
potential Buy in here or was it over
here then that's short in here but then
this one what makes this one so special
and again it doesn't reveal itself
almost immediately but what do you have
on this low okay well yeah you got the
Divergence right you got the nice
positive Delta
um
you've got a nice stacked bind imbalance
and another binding balance a bit higher
you know all these thin prints in here
zero one three zero
three so someone is coming in here
aggressively buying off this low you
know 67 and proceeds to go up and then
sort of pulls back a little bit pulls
back about 50 percent of this move here
right from here
to here
um
it's really quick here let's put this
little volume profile
you can see it pulls back you know
towards the value area of low of this
move from this low to this high
and then as it starts to move up you
know again you know for people that like
to do retracements
and you could sort of do I don't know
what that retracement is but um you know
for me I like levels you know I like the
half back level and just visually I
think halfback is probably right around
here 69 and a half sort of a pullback of
50 before going up
um but as you start going up then you
see the let me close this down here you
can see how it came down to the value
area low traded right below and then
rejected these lower prices here and
started moving up that's how I like to
use this value area
this volume profile I like to take it
from lows to swing highs right the lows
of the data swing high or even you know
from a
swing High to a swing low different ways
to use it but as you start going up okay
now you can see the market now you can
just sort of see people coming in
tripping over themselves looking to get
long aggressively
right you see the Stacked imbalance here
but more importantly look at these
Deltas 936 327 863 737 what makes these
Deltas different
is they're closing right near our Max
Delta number which is how Max Delta
remember is how strong the aggressive
bind was in a bar okay 938 closed at 936
328 close at 327 876 close at 863 737
would close right on 737 and more
importantly another
important thing to pay attention to the
market internal is the Min Delta so you
have Max Delta Min Delta Min Delta tells
you how aggressive
the sellers were in a bar at you know
the most aggressive they were
just as the max Delta tells you how
aggressive the buyers were and here
you're seeing -1 so one contract the
aggressive sellers were in control over
zero minus 57 okay not bad
and then a zero so not only do you see
the
aggressive buying dominating
in terms of the Delta closing near our
strongest readings but you also see the
aggressive sellers never had control
over these basically over this four
minute period you'll even go five minute
period here six minutes and here you
have minus 301 but you got the minus one
here minus one zero fifty Seven minus 57
rather and zero and it's just tilted
more towards the aggressive line so you
can just see people coming in
aggressive Traders coming in
I mean you see a sign like that it's you
know you know it's bullish then you got
the other abandoned value area in here
right and you just sensing okay maybe
maybe this time we've put in our low
right earlier in the day right we had
this potential buying opportunity
um where was it you know this one I
thought this was a legitimate buying
opportunity here
but you don't see that sort of same
aggression many people say well you have
a stacking balance here you got you know
some buying imbalances spread out okay
that's two bars you know these deltasels
are kind of strong 1144
um 1309 okay it's two bars but there's
no continuation right there's nothing
else right you're just going off of that
part
okay but you still got you know
aggressive sellers coming in here but no
follow-through in this bar
okay whereas here after you hit the 940
as you start to Rally right coming in
here
it just looks optically looks more
bullish okay and it's you know it
reaches this previous level here just
sort of goes sideways and then you're
seeing again more bullish activity right
you see the Deltas right the the cyan
color
field here I don't need to pay attention
to what the number is all I know is it's
bullish in that sense right here I see
this is zero so I know aggressive
sellers aren't really aren't ever in
control in this bar here is a minus six
right I see a stacked imbalance here
another couple imbalances here I see the
bar spreading out the Market's looking
for liquidity and then it pops here at
10 20 and it just keeps going up up you
know it just pauses a little bit let's
say pauses but goes sideways
and runs again right another stack
buying about something look at this bar
okay you got this stack binding balance
down here
values up near the top we're closing up
near the top of the bar it's very
similar to this bar you got all this
aggressive buying you got The Binding
balances here the stack buying and
balance below the value area look at
this bar right it goes up near the top
again very similar stack behind and
balance down here the value error up
near the top bars closing up near the
top this bar looks very looks like a
smaller version of this bar and looks
like this bar okay so you know history
repeats itself you know it's not going
to be exactly the same but
you know when you see these this type of
activity taking place you know act on it
all right so I hope you guys enjoyed
this video you know hopefully get some
something out of it that you could add
to your trading if you do be sure to
subscribe to the channel and like the
video so thanks everyone I'll see you
guys on the next video bye bye